GUEST SPEAKER: I'm here
to talk to you today
about why mission
of the World Bank's
new Office of
Sustainable Development
should be to promote sustainable
economic development.
First I'll explain what
sustainable development means
in the context of global
investment in developing
countries.
Then I will discuss why
the World Bank ought
to put a premium on these
particular kinds of investments
and why it ought to promote
environmental protection
in its work.
To understand
sustainable development,
we must first understand
that the well-being
of the economic system
is intrinsically
tied to the well-being
of the environment.
The economy's
functioning depends
on inputs from
nature, which is then
exchanged among
various market actors
and eventually output is
waste into the environment.
The economy grows at
a unsustainable rate
when the rate of resource
consumption and waste
production exceeds the rate
in which the environment can
regenerate and absorb
waste products.
It is also important
to note here
that economic growth is simply
a measure of total resource
throughput.
It says nothing about happiness,
health, safety, or sense
of community within a region.
Now that we've
defined growth, we
can contrast it with the
concept of development.
Development is the quality
of improvement of resource
efficiency within a region.
To invest in projects
that promote development
in poor countries is
to invest in projects
that allow people to produce
more with the resources they
already have.
These kinds of projects might
involve investing in education,
investing in the construction
of local hospitals and clinics,
or investing in research and
development of crop seeds
that are less
resource intensive.
While projects that
promote growth simply
increase production
and consumption,
projects that
promote development
increase the efficiency of
production and consumption
towards some end that
enhances human welfare.
Economic growth
is less important
than economic development
because growth,
usually measured
in terms of GDP,
is a flawed measure of progress.
There is nothing
inherently beneficial
about economic growth.
This is because growth only
implies an increase in resource
throughput.
But It doesn't take into account
whether the resources are being
used in ways that efficiently
maximize well-being
while minimizing
resource consumption.
On the other hand,
economic development
does a far better job of
indicating economic progress.
Development implies that
resources are being used
in increasingly efficient ways.
The more developed a
country is, the more
of benefits from
the resources it
has while minimizing its total
consumption of these resources.
As it becomes more and
more clear to people
across the world that
development, not growth, should
be our top priority, then
the base investment goals
would be in line with the
goals of the rest of the world.
This is because investors
will want the same thing
as anyone else, the
maximum amount of benefit
they can get at the lowest cost.
Likewise, individuals
who recognize development
as their goal want to
receive the greatest benefit
from natural resources they use
while minimizing these risks
consumption.
As the UN's international
financial institution,
the World Bank's mission
is to reduce poverty.
It should do this by promoting
economic development which
insures the long-run
integrity of economic systems.
If the bank instead chooses
to promote economic growth,
it will be investing in projects
that contribute to constructing
an unsustainable economic
and social paradigm
with incredible inertia.
The longer economic growth
remains the dominant measure
of progress, the
more difficult it
will be to change
our consumption
patterns in business
practices to ones
that are more sustainable.
The World Bank may
not look very far
in seeking out
philosophical justification
for taking this measure.
Utilitarianism, the common
philosophical foundation
for much of existing
environmental policy,
tells us that we should take
the forward-looking utility
maximizing action.
Choosing to make investments
that promote development, not
growth, is just such an action.
This is because human
well-being, in the long run,
is maximized when the very
goal of the economic system
is to provide for human
needs while maintaining
the integrity of the
environment in the long run.
Human welfare is
certainly not maximized
when the goal of
the economic system
is to simply
maximize consumption
without regard to the
system's long-run viability.
Such economic growth reduces
our collective welfare
because it leads to
depletion of economic inputs,
natural resources, and it
uses raw materials, as well
the accumulation
in economic outputs
which are manifested by
landfills and garbage patches.
Neither of these outcomes are
ones that anyone would want.
If the World Bank's goal is to
reduce poverty in the long run,
then let's take a
long-run view of success.
As a UN initiative with
a moral imperative,
the World Bank should work to
ensure that it's investment
decisions are based on the
utility maximizing philosophy
that promotes long-run
human welfare.
Indeed investments and
development related projects
pay dividends over many
years, while investments
in growth related
projects may only
provide for human needs
for a short period of time.
It is the World
Bank's responsibility
to take into
account the long run
well-being of the environment
because the viability
of economic systems depend
on its sustained integrity.
To promote growth is to promote
the idea that the economy can
continue to flourish
independently
of the environment, an
idea that is a fiction.
However, to promote
development means
to promote human
progress that is
sensitive to the environments
carrying capacity
and actively works to promote
environmental stewardship
while tending to human needs.
This is the goal on which all
economies should be based.
To that end, the
World Bank should
work to promote this idea
in our newest economies
so that they take no
time in choosing the best
method to promote the
progress of their people.
Thank you.